Film Courage: So during your two week notice
(I assume) were you planning out what your
day was going to be like once the six months
was under way?
Screenwriter Christine Conradt: Yeah, I definitely
had a plan and I knew that I wanted to spend
the time writing and I needed to figure out
what I was most efficient at I think and for
me at that time it was structure.
I was always a really good character writer.
So I knew I needed to learn structure better
and that was one of the things I was going
to have to work on better.
I bought the books and so I did all that kind
of stuff and was definitely prepared during
that time so I could jump off and begin my
six month education since six months actually
ticks by pretty quickly.
Film Courage: Yeah [it does].
I’m wondering what was day one like?
Christine Conradt: Oh my gosh.
I don’t even want to think about it.
I think there was a huge sense of relief in
it in that I was finally doing what I what
I should have been doing for the last couple
of years and I felt like I was going to enjoy
every moment of this.
I may only get six months of doing it.
I just really enjoyed that this was the life
of a writer.
Film Courage: And probably it was sort of
bittersweet, too because you thought maybe
that this was the only six months that you
would ever…that this would happen?
Christine Conradt: Exactly but I was thinking
that far ahead because I had a lot of confidence
that I could make it happen.
So I don’t think I got caught up in this
might be the only time I get to do this.
I was just thinking how do I make this last
and how do I make the money last so I can
continue to do it.
Film Courage: How did you know you could trust
yourself?
Because I think that’s probably the number
one thing is knowing you could trust your
time and allocating the right resources.
Christine Conradt: I think I’ve just always
been someone who has trust myself.
In that I guess when it comes to this kind
of a thing, the only one who is going to make
something happen is you.
And I think just in my perspective you have
a lot of control over that.
So I think for me, I’d gotten into USC.
It was a very competitive program.
I graduated at the top of my class.
I had won awards while I was there.
I knew I was a good writer.
I wasn’t sure why I wasn’t working.
Like I wasn’t sure why I wasn’t selling
scripts.
And so for me a lot of it was like well it’s
not because you’re not a good writer.
It’s because you’re distracted, you’re
not focused.
So you’ve just got to get this back and
once you do, you’ll be able to move forward.
And I think that’s where my head was at
the time.
Film Courage: I think for so many people it’s
that big dilemma of “Do I want to be comfortable
and have a job and have one that has a good
title and that friends and family are going
to respect and that I respect myself for having.
Or do I want to (unfortunately) have life
be a little bit uncomfortable?”
So were you prepared to be uncomfortable,
whether it’s cutting back on spending or
whatever?
Christine Conradt: Oh yeah…and I think I
still am to this day.
I think I would tell any writer that, you
have to be willing to sell your nice car,
to sell your house and move back into an apartment.
You have to love this job more than you love
anything you own because it can go away like
that.
Just because you have some success doesn’t
mean you should ever get comfortable with
it because things change, the industry is
always changing, you’re changing, you’re
getting older, there are new people coming
in, there is so much in flux all the time
that you really have to be in a place where
you’re willing to give that up.
You have to love it enough.
And if you don’t want it enough and you
really just want money, there are a lot easier
ways to go make money than to be a screenwriter.
So that would be my advice.
Film Courage: During the 6 months, were you
doing this seven days a week?
Christine Conradt: Yes.
But it didn’t feel like work because I felt
like I was finally getting to do what I really
wanted to do.
And I woke up every morning loving to write.
I couldn’t wait to get back on the script
and keep working on it.
So it never felt like work to me.
Film Courage: So lastly if someone said to
you “Christine I know this is a huge risk
and I know that I shouldn’t take a line
of credit out or something else (use up my
savings, whatever it is) but I want to risk
it and I’m willing to face the consequences.”
What would you say are some hard and fast
do’s and don’ts?
Film Courage: That’s a great question.
I would say go into it with a plan.
You can’t waste a single minute of that
time, so go into it with a plan.
And tell other people your plan, if this is
what you want to do…first of all if you
tell many people that you’re going to spend
your life savings to make a film or to present
to be a screenwriter for 6 months.
Most people told me not to do it.
They thought I was crazy.
But I think you have to ask yourself those
really hard questions like how much do you
trust yourself, how much are you willing to
lose and give up.
You can always go back and get a job at a
Y or a State Farm or wherever you were working.
And in general successful people tend to be
successful no matter what they do, right?
So if you were being promoted at that job,
you can get another job.
You’ll probably be promoted at that job
as well.
But I would say go into it with a plan and
know what you want to get out of it and have
a way to measure that success.
Because a lot of times I think writers, were
not very good a measuring what’s working
for us and what isn’t.
We just sort of kind of willy-nilly just go
“Oh, today I feel like writing this.
And now this script is done.
And maybe tomorrow I will turn it in and maybe
I won’t.”
You have to really look at your life like
a business.
And if you can manage it in that way, you’re
better prepared for seeing what’s working
and continuing on that route.
Or seeing what’s not working an abandoning
that strategy.
So you have to look at it more like a business.
That’s a big thing, too.